hello and welcome to this video playing
mr. I cannot pronounce the name okay so
i have no idea i usually have ride
against him yeah this variation I think
I want to learn this and I didn't didn't
do so up to now I'm going to just play
this this variation here and see what
happens I usually play with Bishop c5
but I don't fare so well in those
positions so i figured i might go for
for this it seems like pretty normal
kind of development him I think they
often played this kind of stuff protect
the be porn for you maybe I just have to
do that when would be one hits but I
don't know ok I've six shouldn't be
terrible to play ok I think age 3 will
happen no interesting I was thinking
that white is some not allowing Bishop
age 3 here it's not the end of the world
if I get it in but I felt like it is
usually prevented that's probably going
Bishop h1 anyway ok is so now maybe b6
m4 coupe 2d eight
hmm ok ok probably just taking on this
you for an idea here before is an
interesting move night each form even g5
is kind of an option ok I'm trying it I
have my doubts but it's a it's it's by
far more ambitious and then taking which
should be ok but here he has to really
go for go for this and ok if I go g5
here he might sacrifice he might
sacrifice it takes take screen g7 Queen
d5 check as maybe maybe that's not even
working 25 rupees six Quincy six Bishop
d3 so that might work Wow even though
it's very tough position ok I'm going to
do it I have my doubts again ok it just
goes back I was still thinking Bishop g5
could be a move that it wasn't
completely off the mark that this might
work ok I'm trying to do this Knight to
c4 bit I'm a little bit all over the
place he I hope that it's not backfiring
but his pieces on h1 energy to really
look weird so maybe it is ok Queen to e2
i also have Bishop g4 if he tries to
cover see for that way
yeah brookie 192 what pieces look really
weird
I'm still nervous about bishop takes you
five I mean it's not working here quite
clearly because it doesn't have any
attacking pieces to follow it up but in
general maybe I should flick in age six
sometime just to make this sacrifice
less likely
it's taking a long time you know what I
understand it's difficult but no not not
disconnected or anything nope yeah don't
know maybe d5 was something like that
trying to activate something always
doorbell rang that's all so they're
always always a possibility
Twilight's uncanny probably really a
doorbell or something like that
okay so i wanted to go there anyway well
maybe Bishop g5 then gets more now I can
go to h eight yeah I can go to NJ it's
up this isn't business possible okay
once the night on I wants to put the
nerd on nerd III I have a funny
continuation here what about this and
then this yes to play that if there's no
other move so what now just take the
exchange that's not totally clear cut
yeah i think i will though at least
gives me a clear concept on how to win
this game grabbing material so what now
I don't know if I want to take them or
flame what's tricky but should try to be
I should try to play quickly here okay
so the light squares are weakish I
wonder if this is a movement maybe just
make sure that nothing comes to f5 by
putting something on there five myself
yeah that seems ok his bishop is still
not doing much yeah okay
putting pressure on deform yeah and I'm
going to push that him yes and now it's
not now it's bishop is dead yeah that's
good that's good no d5 this Bishop 'if
I've
as plain without the bishop them that is
it's really a huge problem Queen g6 s
Bishop f3 this is something I probably
want to avoid 92 maybe hmm ok happy 3
which should be enough I can take he
actually this is a good move it's a nice
little trick threatening Queen h2 and if
he takes f to check King takes III
winning the Queen so nice law tactic
check
white resigns okay well I don't know it
looked kind of okay for me i don't i
don't think he had anything I'm great at
any point I was Ted surprised that he
had allowed this kind of thing to happen
I was thinking not that it is so bad but
I was thinking that what should should
should shoot for something like this and
then g-form know maybe I also go to his
six I don't know but I was thought I was
a bit surprised that that this was
allowed yeah now okay I can't play
something simple like taking that efore
is the more interesting move because his
night only has this is somewhat weird
square on h4 and now g5 yeah it really
depends on if he can sacrifice or not my
line mmm ok the engine wants to take and
I think this is this is a critical move
check what I was seeing is this this and
then I saw look to e6 but probably this
is just bad because you can take on your
phone okay I was thinking this when i
saw this line and I'm fine but
this is possible when 97 which is
actually not clear at all this is the
line that stopped which is giving at
wide wins now I'm totally overloaded
here so that line did not work yeah what
the engine is giving is this coming to
have seven here and if the Queen takes
Bishop d7 and the queen is strapped oh
my goodness now I don't know I don't
know what happened if you would have
taken their own g5 I mean I probably
would have noticed that my plan rookie
successfully wit ya here I'm just
clearly better yeah and it is giving me
a large plus more than one pawn yeah
this was ultimately losing stuff after
more than two minutes but yeah that's
really funny the White Queen doesn't
have any anything anywhere to go yeah
engine is playing very mercilessly with
Queen to f7 night here Nana can actually
take for us hmm the computer is giving
this just kind of crazy just playing
playing this position now kate i was i
just took stuff because if you take
material you at least have a clear
concept on how your wind looks like
avenue just win by the material and
sometimes this is just a good way to go
just grab stuff and and see how you win
with the material yeah this is after
this I was pretty confident that I will
win because I'm an exchange up but it's
also that this Bishop is not playing
some you know this is a nice short check
no wins wins everything yeah that's it
seemed like a pretty pretty pretty okay
game thanks for watching